animal adoptions they are way up with
many people who are stuck at home
looking for the companionship of pets
and the scammers they've noticed first
on cbs this morning a new better
business bureau report on pet scams
shows complaints this year have more
than doubled from last year
consumer investigative correspondent
that's anna warner has been looking into
this
and a good morning to you here's a
question how scuzzy do you have to be
to scam lonely people with puppies
it just tugs at everything yeah
yeah i wish we knew the answer to that
and the bbb says americans
have lost more than two million dollars
to these scammers
who have also left some real heartbreak
there's something everyone seems to want
right now
pets they can love in the case of
jeannie dixon of spokane washington
it was to help with the loss of her
daughter 19-year-old
charlene who died after a knee surgery
last year
charlene was going to change the world
she was
a magnificent beautiful loving kind girl
one thing her daughter always wanted she
says was a newfoundland puppy
and in her grief dixon says she decided
to get one
i sought out a puppy
to honor charlene's legacy
and let her know how much i loved her so
in june dixon found the website newfee
home.com
advertising as a newfoundland breeder in
tulsa she picked out a puppy named ben
who the breeder assured her would be
registered and vet checked
we came to an agreement 950 dollars but
after she sent an initial payment she
says
the breeders like the money didn't come
the money didn't come you can put it in
my bank
she says he told her to take the money
to an atm and put it in his account
which she did and i came home and waited
for a puppy
but then the breeder told her via text
she'd have to pay an
additional 15-hundred dollars for what
they called
a refundable insurance fee which she
also paid
and i'm waiting waiting waiting for my
puppy
it wasn't until she got another email
from the breeders so-called shipping
company
telling her she'd now have to pay
another twenty six hundred dollars for a
temperature regulator crate and
anti-pressure vaccine
that she became suspicious it was at
that point that you realized
okay this is not right yeah
right then i realized i've been scammed
scammers are very clever
at tapping into the emotion of the
person they're trying to scam
catherine hutt is with the better
business bureau that's
one of the things that really makes this
so sad you know this is not just a scam
where you lose money this is a scam
where your heart gets broken
her group estimates more than three
quarters of the websites that advertise
puppies for sale
aren't real and this online security
expert says
the pandemic has been a windfall it's
created a perfect storm
for puppy scams he goes by the name paul
brady and runs a website called
petscams.com
monitoring fake breeders people he says
who typically are operating out of
foreign countries including south africa
singapore and cameroon these camps are
run on
on an industrial scale it is arranged
like an actual
gang it is easy money if you're on
cameroon
because the the relative payback is very
high
nearly 4 000 people filed complaints
with the bbb
from january through november victims
saying they lost
nine hundred dollars twenty four hundred
forty seven hundred
even sixty two hundred dollars to pet
scammers
they will keep going until you decide to
stop paying money
jeannie dixon did stop but only after
losing over 2 400 dollars
and the puppy she thought would help
with her grief over losing her daughter
i blame myself because it was a stupid
thing
to do to believe
that i could send money to some
anonymous
person and get some comfort out of that
that was
dumb
well we tried to contact newfiehome.com
and that shipping
company but no one responded the newfie
home
site is now down if you have a story to
tell us about what happened to you
email us won't you at coronavirus at
cbsnews.com coronavirus cbsnews.com
anthony we'd like to hear your stories
yeah all right anna that's these people
are just evil what they're doing to
to to these people who just wants some
comparison exploiting our humanity it's
not
dumb it's human to do what that lady did
and that's
that's what's being exploited what makes
us people no what he said about you not
only do you lose money
what she said you lose money it breaks
your heart that's what i thought yeah
i'm going to change from
that woman is feeling after being
exploited
and all she wanted and losing her
daughter yeah